si jamais vous vous posiez la question
sachez qu'on a désormais la réponse le
président de la République paye son
loyer en 2017 Emmanuel Macron investit
l'Élysée où il était visiblement pressé
et pour loger dans ce 100 m² en plein
cœur du 8e arrondissement le couple
présidentiel paierait bien son loyer
pour la somme de
1000 euros
soit bien que la valeur du marché une
information qui a choqué de nombreux
Français j'ai bien entendu sérieux même
25000 ne serait pas assez pour un tel
palais alors Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron
payent-ils vraiment 2153 euros de loyer
pour habiter à l'Élysée
alors c'est complètement démago on sait
qu'un appartement de 100 m² dans le 8ème
arrondissement ça vaut minimum 5000 6000
euros il y a 300 m² d'appartement au
total en vrai
fonction c'est symbolique c'est un
déprimant mais ils font ça pour faire
croire que le président est un citoyen
par les autres alors non ou pas
l'électricité l'électricité
et on se dit que tu la sens passer à
l'Élysée sur sa fiche de paye sauf que
c'est pas du tout conforme à la réalité
encore une fois un appartement dans le
8e arrondissement pour 2000 euros vous
avez quoi vous avez 40 mètres carrés
donc ils arrêtent de faire croire qu'ils
sont comme les autres ils ont évidemment
pas les appartements privés c'est pas ça
du tout
ensemble du côté de du bureau de Madame
pas de 1500 € Bernard
et c'est soumis à l'impôt là aussi c'est
sur la fiche de paix
et Guillaume ne soit pas démago parce
que par ailleurs si il allait habiter
dans un appartement qu'il payait à part
ça nous coûterait à nous contribuer à
beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il faudrait
[Musique]
avantage en nature sur sa feuille
d'imposition ce qui est tout à fait
normal sinon lui reprocherait de
bénéficier du Mans comme nous on peut on
pourrait le faire comme n'importe quel
particulier davantage en nature il faut
le déclarer donc déjà c'est bien que
grâce au tribunal administratif qu'on
ait ça avant on n'avait jamais ça
il faut mettre la voiture l'avion la
c'est ridicule
il y en a plein qui abusent moi je je
fais pas de politique il y en a plein
c'est sous-évaluer ok c'est plus le prix
d'un 60 mètres carrés que dans 100 m² au
prix du marché d'accord
Benjamin il y avait rien avant la
transparence ça commence petit à petit
Géraldine mais sauf que à force d'aller
fouiller dans les poches de nos élus en
fait on va plus avoir personne qui va
vouloir se présenter parce qu'en fait
le temps est court un député tu peux
être la 4e par exemple
5500 € tous les mois pendant 4 ans moi
je veux bien les prendre
mais non parce que si on était si
malheureux si c'était sensible
ouais mais parce que ça m'énerve les
gens parce que les gens comprend rien on
n'est pas dans le Captain alors
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire fini il va
il va rappeler après mais je trouve que
voilà malgré tout je pense que c'est
quand même c'est c'est pas c'est quand
même des métiers qui sont difficiles et
je pense que
alors vraiment
politique pourquoi ils courent tous pour
aller le faire alors et pourquoi ils le
font pas pour 2000 bases par mois
ils comprennent des politiques vous me
parlez des faites comme en Suède ils y
vont pour 2500 balles il paye tous les
mecs ils payent leur déplacement ils
payent tout parce que si tu as l'amour
ta nation vas-y pour 2005 et 3000 balles
pourquoi ils y vont pour 10000 balles
pourquoi ils vivent pour 6000 balles la
soupe elle est bonne tu en trouveras
toujours pourquoi je me suis pourquoi
j'ai réagi parce que tu m'as dit ils
voudront plus jamais aller faire ils
voudront plus ils ont des apparts
gratuits des voitures gratuites
avec ces diplômes dans le privé monsieur
Macron il pourrait gagner 300000 balles
par mois donc c'est un bon samaritain il
est venu pour nous sauver pendant
longtemps
pour le pouvoir mais pour l'argent sache
que ces mecs gagneraient beaucoup plus
d'argent même Gilles qui évidemment tu
peux lui dire bien sûr
très haut niveau avec des spécialités
qui gagnent des sommes donc connu dans
le monde entier
des fortunes pour croire que ils vont
pas faire de réseau
en fait
on est des bidons partout c'est que tu
arrives tous pourris après non mais
j'entends et que certains abusent mais
il y a pas le tous pourris il y a des
gens qui ont vraiment envie de gouverner
pour faire passer des idées vraiment ils
sont pas tous là pour le pognon sinon je
t'assure qui serait ailleurs et qui
planquerait dans des paradis fiscaux
comme d'autres donc voilà il y a la
transparence et bien en politique moi
c'est magouille moi ça m'étonnerait
moi monsieur
je trouve que c'est un peu indécent
c'est que un mec par exemple est député
et maire il peut avoir le droit à deux
voitures ne peut pas être dans deux
voitures en même temps qu'il a deux
voitures avec deux chauffeurs corvéables
à souhaits ça par exemple tu regardes
pas deux toi tu regardes aucune
normalement il y a beaucoup garde les
deux c'est mieux d'avoir deux voitures
que une voilà c'est un petit gâchis
évidemment